29块 扣个8扣个8
29扣个8
来这个连一圈
这个是一个棉混纺一个白色
这个圈
短袖短袖的这个是微领
前面腰上的话是有个
嗯有个小纽扣里面
里面是个纽扣外面是一个绑带
这一块
是一个短袖这个圈
来胸围
胸围100-106
100-106
来这个长度
长度是98
长度98
来这个有腰的扣
这个29扣8
29块扣8扣8
两边有口袋
29块扣个8扣个8
29扣8
29块扣8
29块扣9块扣9块扣9块扣10块扣10块扣10块扣
来这个鸽子的
我娘啊
这个是个裙子还是个啥
这个是个裙
看看这一款鸽子的一款连一圈
腰上是松紧的呢
腰上是松紧
拼接一个黑色
来这个胸围
这个是锯纸混纺的一个
锯纸还有啥混纺
没有标了
没有标没有标了
来胸围
胸围是106106128
106128来长度长度90的长度90
来这个1919给你们孤品孤品了
1919扣8扣8
19块扣个8
喜欢的必要扣19
这种小格子
19扣819扣8
19块扣个8
这个是啥鱼网
黄色的一个大鱼网
看看全是大洞呢
这个鱼网鱼网
威灵威灵
我娘啊
这么大一个
这么大一个来腰胸围量一下
胸围是112112140
112140长度长度76长度76
来这个给你们9块9块扣个6
这么大一个全是鱼网了
9块9块扣6扣6
面料是尼龙混纺的
应该这种
看见没很密实
这个面料很好
19直接9块给你们9块扣6
9块9块放超低福利了
姐妹们扣6扣6
来这个灰色的一个哈伦库
灰色灰色一个哈伦库来腰围
腰围7274
腿围961
当场34后场93
来这个9块9块扣个3
灰色灰色这一条9块9块喜欢扣3扣3
这一条裤子
9元扣个3
这个应该含一点点毛
里面有内衬
这个应该含一点毛
有一点点渣内衬到这个位置
内衬到这里摸一下
到这里
内衬到这里
这底下一点点没有内衬
上面都有内衬
9块9块扣8扣8
9块钱扣个8
来这个短款的一个卫衣
短款一个卫衣
短款短款这个是上面
这一款短款的一个黑色卫衣
刚货到一个灰色的
这个是个黑
来胸围
胸围是100到120
100120的胸围来长度长度44
这个1919扣4
1919扣4扣4
19块扣个4
19块19块
来这个棉汇访棉汇访的一个圈
这样的一个圆领领口字
腰上也是松紧的
腰上也是松紧下摆是长短不一的
这个下摆是这样子的
来这个胸围看看
棉棉婚纺不确定棉多少
这个没见过洗胶
胸围胸围9696110
96110长度90到100
长度90100
这个1919扣0
19块扣0扣0单层不透
单层不透
这个腰上是松紧腰
然后这个袖子的话是这样的一个袖子
颜色也好看
面料又软又舒服
透气性好
这个19块扣0
这个是含棉的
棉含的要多一些
不确定棉多少
19块19块
今天又好痒
来这一款
白色白色这条哈林裤
白色的一条哈林裤
来腰围
腰围是70-74
70-74
平围94106
端长33
裤长93
来这个19块
扣3扣3
1919扣个3
白色白色
这个少扣子了
9块给你们了
9块少了一个扣
有扣眼缺扣子了
9块扣3
9块9块扣个3
6块钱扣个3
这条就是直线的
10块一个
有入力了
有水了
拿这一条裤子
鼻子今天好痒
这条裤
这个塞尔欧号
棉52
巨指41
人棉7
这一条
这个叫什么
什么颜色的
哈林裤
这个裤子稍微厚一点
春秋天可以穿
腰尾72
唇尾
唇尾98
当场
当场34
裤长98
来这个
39扣8
39块
扣8扣8这一块
39扣8扣8
39扣个8
39块
39扣8扣8
39扣8扣8扣8
这个腰大
这个是三二楼的
这个牌子
这个牌
三二楼的一个巨指
三二楼的
人字纹的
这个是这种条纹的
人字纹的大阔腿
看看这么大一个
这个是三二欧
起码也大
起码最小腰在80左右了
84能拉伸10
唇尾130到136
当场三
当场41
裤长95
这个有腰的扣
来这个29
能穿扣个5
29块
扣5扣5
29这个腰大
29扣5扣5
violated
29扣5
31扣6
40的
õ
说
statistically
ряд
每个老 desperate
这有个格子啊
sodium
key
就是
委托
You wear
kelvin
captions
弯
romance
代表
日
据说
decompose
Exp orang
制作
紧急
VR
开始
―
你看
在
还
filtration
格子
咋
缩
铔
最
两边是来这个腰围
腰围66到84
66 84
腿围92 110
当场34
裤长95
这个29
29扣3
能穿的扣
29块扣3扣3
这里
这次它染色不均匀
这个是染色不均匀
有一条黑色线
29 29扣3扣3
格子格子的这一款
用的是M码
29扣3
拿这一款
这个是一个小西装
这个是
那个叫什么
叫什么牌子
就啥啥牌子
我又给忘了一下
高尔夫的高尔夫的
胸围98 108
98 108的
胸围长度60
来这个19
19扣6
1919扣个6
19扣个6
19扣个7
19扣个8
19扣个9
19扣
19 minima
这个腰好大
这个补过了
这个腰大了
哎呦
我妈呀
多少度
20不得18度
咱们这么冷一下
打喷嚏了
感冒还没好了
来这一款
这个是艾欧尺玛的
艾欧尺玛
橘子64
棉32
娟日4
这个牌子
蓝色一个藏蓝色
后半边松紧的
前面有出绳
是一个哈伦裤
橡蓝色的
来这个腰围
腰围的话是72
72 96
臀围108120
来这个裆长
裆长36
裆长96
这个有腰的
39块
扣6扣6
扣6扣6这一块
39扣个6
这个小西装
高尔夫的这个西装
19块
扣8扣8
19这样子的
19块扣个8
19扣8扣8
小西装
19扣8
来这一条
这一条是这个牌子
这个牌
这个牌子的全松紧
前面有抽绳
这个绳子
是男士的一个运动裤
腰围72
72 102
臀围
臀围108124
裆长36
裆长90
来这个39
扣3
39块
扣3扣3这一条
运动休闲的一条裤子
39扣3
对了
看不到了
,39
来这一条
这个薄的很
我天呐
软软糯糯的
你看很薄
这一条裤薄的很
这一条裤藏蓝色
全半松紧
前面有抽绳
腰围70到96
70 96
臀围112
2发
臀长34
裆长91
来这个39块
扣2扣2
39扣个2
扣个2的一块
39块
扣个2而已
39扣个2
这有个厚的呢
厚的一条
运动的一条裤
全松紧
有抽绳
这个是一个
一个黑色的吧
来咯
是吗
腰围70
70到92
70 92
腿围108126
裆长37
裆长93
来这个39扣3